bitter poison come unsavoury guide you
desperate pilot set the sea weary ship
into the rocks here's to my love that
pharmacist was honest if drugs were
quickly so I die with the kiss
[Music]
[Music]
Romeo Romeo Romeo
[Music]
you'd shown the one from the play Oh
Jordan
slightly less charming little horrific
actually oh I can't look at these Jordan
was my first hashtag squad Cole's
interview that's so sad so what they're
saying it was his peanut allergy
it's so weird you can die from that I
don't even get how it happened
he was so vigilant about it we know who
schools there was nothing in the
lunchroom nothing in the vending
machines I know so unfair I haven't had
a Snickers bar since like middle school
was saying my rights have been violated
hey how's everything going at home well
aside from my folks being called home
from a romantic weekend getaway because
at that body in the driveway oh that I
mentioned that not one but two of my
dad's cherished antique knives were
stolen from his office the office that I
told you to not let anybody into well
aside from that I guess you could say
that everything's just hunky-dory
thank you how long do you think it'll
take to get the results from the
lipstick seriously dude
hey that sucks yeah
i'm garna for a freakin month sorry man
um did the police ever follow up with
you or anything what can they say
yeah I didn't break any laws you were
with me when she fell and even the cops
said that I can't control what anyone
brings in or does to the house so Lisa
it's under control
Hey well at least there's something
positive yeah all right let's get to
this and then one else came like a Nancy
Drew's mystery vibe hey I'm Nate Nate
Sam Sam Nate has something he wants to
tell you and I'm a ghost ladies okay I'm
gonna say something to you okay
but before I do let me just say that I
had a plan
to wait for the perfect moment you know
like a movie moment where we could be in
a situation one of those cool situations
and I could spontaneously I have you
know no idea what you're talking about
I'm either let me just start over so
you know I'm a big bitter sarcastic dark
doofus right right
wow this is embarrassing I'm a big dark
doofus who has a big big crush on you
there I said it now Rudy can leave me
alone
don't say anything we're friends I know
you can just you know sit with it for a
bit you or me and then reject me later
my dear Juliet why are you still so
beautiful powerful performance so I die
with the kiss so what they're saying it
was his peanut allergy I don't even get
how it happened
he was so vigilant about it hello who's
there Lance
rumor has it this totally opens up the
scholarship yeah Jordan was assumed you
mean the whole world patron thing oh
it's sweet deal I mean full books and
board everything they did manage to get
a copy of the world patron scholarship
finalists so after Jordan Brittany's
nexts speaking of the scholarship how do
you think it's a little more than
coincidental that most of the people on
it or Ted we're sitting was funny maybe
it's just about to him what you kind of
do wait a minute what was the last thing
that touched his lips Angela's lips
voila
positive for peanut residue who the hell
did this anybody there I'm pretty sure
somebody's following me who's following
you really this is just too creepy
nobody's asking any questions
nobody's doing anything this is not a
game Samantha this is as serious as it
gets
he needs that scholarship more than
anyone else and what's scariest I'm the
last one in line for the scholarship he
gets rid of me she's got it
you
you